hi everybody I'm Nancy O'Dell with an ET
special feature every other day we feel
sore and then we feel good and then we
have a hard rehearsal and then we feel
sore I think we're good we definitely
know our routine so we started to work
on the waltz yeah and we're gonna fight
about music that's the only thing trying
to figure out I think I think we've been
pretty good so far the the biggest
problem is I like to wear sneakers I
don't like to wear the dance shoes and
let ivenna said I'm going to get hurt if
I don't wear the dance shoes so knock on
what it hasn't happened yet
but I need to start listening to my
partner because she's the expert the
very first day we met he walked into the
room and he was so serious like there
was an event like a glimpse of a smile
or a hint of it and he goes well I
really wanted you I requested you and
here you are and I wasn't sure if that
was a good or a bad thing young like yes
is that is that good are we happy he's
like we're very happy yeah I think
there's a celebratory dance inside he's
like yay but outside is James Bondish so
searching through Sean since again oh I
kind of stumbled upon something special
yes I love I love the touch of candles
it it makes it even more romantic so
that's the only one like you had the
other one American oh yeah I start out
like I like that one yeah I went three
Instagram team not not in a stocking
yeah shirt off we're waiting till I get
a proper tan a California tan I won't
get spray tan so what happens is we
rehearse and then I have to go
immediately to pool and get
some tanning times so top flight
probably be like week five week six I
need three more weeks I actually had a
glimpse of abs like the other day when
he was changing um he's ready he is
ready those ABS are ready to be revealed
but you know what they need to color
correct on the show I think anyway that
was for a Calvin Klein campaign my
Colin's the first one I posted instagram
took it down had too much of an outline
so that's why I improvised manic the
candle touch I know they can't do dices
great makes it run into men no no hi I
wanted to see you like set it up in the
Millburn like light the candles to the
light in walk around